so let's get started off looking at kind
of the big picture right the 30,000 foot
view what's going on in Asian economies
if you look at the size of the world's
top five biggest economies you see that
the u.s. is still the single national
largest economy in the whole world
China's number two India is now number
three and Japan has moved to number four
that was a change that happened really
between 2010 and 2011 partly you're
seeing a huge issue I'm sorry 2011 in
2012 you're seeing a huge issue with the
disaster in Tohoku that led to minus
growth in Japan that year oh you're
seeing a general slowdown across the top
economies but kind of keep an eye out on
the world growth rate at
three-point-three percent and kind of
watch what's happening to other
countries as we go along so these are
the top five countries notice both China
and India had ten percent growth back in
2010 this is dropped back noticeably the
growth the growth rate decline in China
arguably has had a much bigger impact
than that in India and we'll see that
especially when you see what I would
call the jumping-off points to China
these are the other Asian countries that
make it into the top 50 countries of the
world in terms of the size of their
economies and some really shocking stuff
here first of all look at singapore from
fourteen point eight percent growth in
2010 to 2.1 percent growth in 2012 wow
taiwan from 10.7 percent growth to
one-point-three percent growth on kong
from seven point one percent growth to
one point eight percent growth notice
these countries are now below the world
average even though they were
considerably above the world average in
2010 one factor may be the slowdown in
the in the China economy a lot of these
companies other economies were really
kind of jumping off points to China and
arguably the two or three percent slow
down that's happened across China has
had a much bigger impact on these other
countries now there are other things
going on too one of them is probably the
uncertainty in financial markets that
was always been a big part of Hong Kong
and Singapore but it hit Taiwan just
about as bad and the financial sector is
not that big an element of the Taiwan
economy so that's one thing that's going
on another thing that's going on is that
you you see kind of a slowdown in Korea
to from six point three percent to
two-point-seven percent that may have to
do with slow down in the the economy in
China but it could just be you know kind
of other sort of supply chain issues
that are going on Korea may be getting
less outsourced to manufacturing than it
used to because of the increase in its
wage levels notice that Korea now has a
GDP per person which is roughly
equivalent to income of thirty two
thousand dollars which starts to put it
into the expensive country category the
Southeast Asian countries are
interesting because they haven't slowed
down so much Indonesia from six point
two percent to six percent there's a
great example now in the middle of this
you get some strange stuff thailand went
from seven point eight percent through a
period of 0.1 percent to five point six
percent anybody take a guess why
flooding you got it direct hit just like
the big
a stir in Japan in 2011 Malaysia 7.2 %
to 4.4% Philippines seven point six
percent to four point eight percent on
Vietnam six point eight percent to 5.1
percent the Southeast Asian countries
are still higher growth rate than the
world average now there are various
tendencies growth rates tend to decline
as the individual income levels go up
the size of the economy is bigger and so
it's harder to get an extra three
percent on an economy when it's a giant
economy than it is when it's a smaller
economy but still this is a very
interesting kind of pattern that you see
here um yeah okay we talked about that
it's really these jumping-off points to
China that are now well below the
average growth rates for the world and
India also had a noticeable slow down
but that really hasn't been as obviously
connected to the situation in other
economies we do see a big shift in the
Chinese economy I think that China has
been a gold rush and that means that
getting to the Goldfield faster than
anybody else was extremely important now
government policy is much more focused
on constraining domestic growth and
managing the kind of economic bubble so
that it doesn't all burst at once there
is a noticeable shift in the trade
balance in China it used to be that
China was running over a ten percent
account surplus that's down to two or
three percent which means that more
Chinese output is staying in the Chinese
domestic economy that is a huge shift
there are some other things that you
know they may be noise but you got to
think about them political change in
China Japan and Korea especially in
China typically takes months for a new
government to sort of take form and that
just sort of made everything wait for a
while
from last October Japan and South Korea
also have brand new government's I was
in Korea at the beginning of I'm sorry
not the beginning of this month but last
week and everybody was waiting to see
who would be the new ministers the
territorial disputes over the islands in
the middle of the Pacific have reduced
trade between Japan and other Asian
countries that has impacted trade
between Japan and China and also Japan
and Korea and you know all the
uncertainties about the EU starting with
Greece and going through Portugal and
now lately with Cyprus has had an impact
on things the US elections probably had
an impact on things although definitely
see an uptick in the feeling of the
American economy at the beginning of
2013 but what is probably a more
important change is a structural
transformation that is really in the
early stages of hitting China and other
recently developed Asia economies and
that is a shift toward more emphasis on
knowledge intensive industries you can
also look at this you can also call it a
shift to being an innovation driven
economy the OECD has a technical term
that they call knowledge and technology
intensive industries and if you notice
how much of the American economy comes
from knowledge intensive industries and
it's a lot more in 2010 than it was in
1995 you see a similar jump up by more
than five percent of the economy
increased to be part of it from these
knowledge intensive and knowledge and
technology intensive industries in the
EU Japan is also kind of up in this but
then you get the bricks and with the
bricks it's still only about twenty
percent of the economy is accounted for
by knowledge intensive industries
but if you look at the share of GDP that
is contributed by high-tech
manufacturing in the United States
that's floated around for the last you
know for 15 years or so it's floated
around this thirty percent figure with
Japan it's actually declined in China
this number is going up pretty
drastically so these are the percentages
over here that's the actual dollar
contributions over here the Asia eight
countries I've got on the slide the this
is national science foundation they send
out these indicators every year
similarly okay got to walk over here
anyway similarly if you look at the new
US patent registrations who's first
inventor has a foreign address you see
that Japan is by far the country that
supplies the most US patents outside the
US there's been the case for a long time
the Asia eight is definitely increasing
notice how China has started from almost
nothing but it's now on the showing
showing up on the chart if you look now
at that as a percentage you see that
Japan's percentage is declining the e
u--'s percentage is declining and Asia
eight is going up noticeably especially
Korea especially other
manufacturing-related economies and also
China is on the way up so what you're
seeing is you're seeing a greater
integration you wouldn't file for a US
patent unless you want to do business in
the US patent only protects you in the
country where you file so if you file a
US patent it's probably because you've
already filed in your home country that
means that you think this is valuable
enough to pay the filing fee in the
maintenance fee in the United States as
well these tend to be regarded as
high-value patents and so you know what
you're seeing you're seeing an
increasingly international rd community
number of papers published in S&T
journals
japan is flat for 15 years but look at
China definitely long-term investment in
science and technology this would be
even before you've got a patent in the
offing right this is earlier stage
research more basic stage research Asia
8 is moving up Asia 10 is the Asia 8
plus Japan and China so here's the Asia
India Indonesia Malaysia Philippines
Singapore South Korea Taiwan and
Thailand what's happening one of the
things that's happening is a major
change in Asia thats related to economic
development there's a group called the
Global Entrepreneurship monitor that
I'll talk about more in just a minute
and they separate economies into three
stages they don't call them developing
economies and whatever anymore they call
them factor driven economies which to
most people would be industrializing
economies efficiency driven economies
and then innovation-driven economies and
if you look at the kind of things that
happen you see the change in the types
of opportunities that you find in
different countries China has been a
gold rush a huge gold rush you've had
massive urbanization with millions of
people moving into the cities who didn't
live there a lot of China is
industrializing in ways that it wasn't
industrial a few years ago to be
competitive in China getting there first
seems to be a major factor you don't
have people spending a lot of time
developing elegant technologies for a
market like that you get there first and
you make money and then you can develop
technology as you go along the focus of
government laws in this kind of a
situation is on establishing an industry
base this is one stage when you start to
get protectionist legislation and you
also have a lot of kind of basic laws
basic laws about how you know commercial
codes and so forth
the second stage of this kind of
development macro economic development
typically what happens is you've got so
many people and so many new factories
that there are label shortages and
capital shortages the government becomes
very concerned with making sure that it
allocates labor and capital efficiently
so that people are not wasting their
time and things that are not going to
lead to anything Oh in this kind of
stage is where you get very strong
manufacturing skills this is where
countries like Japan in the 1960s and
Korea in the 1980s were clearly opening
up new markets either domestic or
international and they were focusing on
efficiency rapid scaling especially in
manufacturing so high quality of goods
at the last stage innovation-driven
economies are a different kind of thing
first of all you really only need a high
school education to work in a factory
most people but that generation of
people has children that they educate
and as education spreads throughout the
population kids don't want to do the
same work that their parents did they
have a desire for greater opportunities
that they're looking for in this kind of
a situation the opportunities really
come from out-of-the-box thinking this
is where you get people who come up with
ideas that nobody knew they needed until
they saw them right the definition of
innovation as applied to Steve Jobs he
knew what people needed before they
could figure it out in this kind of a
situation managing risk allowing risk in
the right way running an efficient
commercialization an efficient
innovation system is absolutely critical
and being able to sustain growth for
major companies becomes more and more
difficult this is where you get the
government support for entrepreneurship
this is where you get government support
for
things like small business innovative
research grants SBIR grants that came
into the US from the late 1990s
mid-1990s I should say and what they do
is they allow start-up ideas to have a
little bit more money so that they can
get to market it subsidizes the
commercialization so these kind of
changes are going on in Asia right now
if you look at the United States we
really don't have one single system
Silicon Valley is the innovation based
economy to halt innovation based
economies however most of the other
regions in the US are considerably
behind here if you go to some place like
Detroit if you go to some place like the
American southeast you will find places
where the attitudes are very different
they're very different toward
entrepreneurship they're very different
toward risk now to have an Innovation
Center like Silicon Valley you must have
a symbiotic relationship with a good
market the growth of silicon valley
until about nineteen ninety-five was
probably mostly due to the US market
since 95 I would say we are really more
global than we are sensitive to the US
we are very heavily focused on Asia here
in Silicon Valley if you go to the US
East Coast you don't really get the kind
of focus on China and India and Korea
and Malaysian wherever that you do here
Japan and Korea were so successful at
this efficiency stage that has been very
difficult for them to get out of these
risk-averse pick the winner get a good
job with a prestigious company kind of
attitude and very difficult to open up
with the kind of freewheeling approach
to innovation that you really need at
stage three stage three looks very
uncertain that looks very risky it's not
a future that you want your children to
have China is trying to avoid stage two
and have some sort of a hybrid between
this major manufacturing base
and an innovation based economy all at
once it's going directly from the gold
rush into a model that's trying to
exploit its innovation capabilities but
maintain a very strong manufacturing
base partly through a lot of attention
to domestic market development but I
think that it will be really interesting
to see how China's very compressed
economic development will play into this
in India what you've got is moving from
a stage one kind of you know
industrializing economy to a place that
have islands of incredibly advanced
innovation based activities right
alongside bottom of the pyramid kind of
business opportunities and this makes
the kind of attention to the bottom of
the pyramid that you see among the
innovation community in India extremely
interesting because they may come up
with ideas of how to solve problems of
very poor communities that we would
never come up with in a more advanced
economy so this is what's going on how
does this impact entrepreneurship first
of all any questions or comments about
that section before we move on go ahead
I'll and I heard a statistic the other
day that I was wondering if you could
confirm or that whether this is just
speculation but and I heard that the
Asian middle class was grown from about
500 million right now to 1.75 billion in
seven years this was a Singaporean
visitor at an inch you know on TV
program and I saw and and how that
plates into both the macro economic
development and entrepreneurial
opportunities as a result of it that's
about right I mean I've got a slide in
Japanese that I gave
presentation a few months ago that
pretty much confirms that by country now
what you see is you see India in
continuing a very rapid growth of the
middle class right and in China you see
a trail off in the projection around
2025 because of the aging population and
that's going to be an impact on a number
of countries in Asia that is maybe a
slowing will slow down this increase of
the middle class because people go to
fixed income after they retire but yes a
lot of this has to do with the
appearance of a new set of consumers
consumer of activities let's see
consumer the part of GDP consumer
activities in China have been growing
between twelve and sixteen percent a
year and the GDP growth was never more
than about 10.5 so a lot of it is fuel
more and more by consumption and less by
investment but China is really
interesting this slowdown that's been
happening over the last year is having
some major impact and one of the first
places we see major impact as an
entrepreneurship I got some data I want
to present from a group called the
Global Entrepreneurship monitor and just
so you know who these people are it was
really Babson College and partnership
with the london business school every
year they do a survey of over a hundred
thousand people so the 2012 survey was
almost 200,000 people that they
interviewed in 69 different economies
meaning countries right and they do two
surveys an adult population survey and
they also do a national expert survey so
what I've got for you today all comes
from this adult population survey and
the key kind of rate that I want to look
at is what is often called the tier 8
and this is total early-stage
entrepreneurial activity
people in who are grown ups but not too
old who are either a nascent
entrepreneur or the owner manager of a
new business and they've got specific
definitions of this either if you're an
ace and entrepreneur you're setting up a
business but you haven't paid a salary
if you're the owner manager of a new
business you've paid wages and salary to
the owners for at least three months but
no more than 42 months beyond that you
get established business even if it's a
small business okay so they haven't a
special term for this tier 8 so if you
look at the tier 8 in the United States
it has gone to about 13% this is not too
drastic a change after a downturn you
typically see a reduction in the tier 8
in an advanced economy because people
are afraid of they can't get money the
investors don't give money right and
and so earn and the in the percentage of
people who are actively involved in
either starting or growing a brand new
company but the first really drastic
kind of thing you see on this graph is
China when I pointed this out last year
twenty four percent of the population in
China was actively engaged in starting
or running a new company and that
dropped in one year to thirteen percent
which is an incredible kind of outcome
some sort of a psychological process a
combination of psychological process and
also the availability of capital as
we'll see a little bit later venture
capital investments were down by forty
percent in china between 2012 and 2011
right now thailand has the highest tier
eight that you'll find and you know then
you get kind of in the middle the Tigers
tend to be in the middle oh except for
taiwan which is moved up to twelve
percent people involved in tier eight
again really you've got Singapore and
Malaysia and Hong Kong all kind of down
around this seven or eight percent area
and then down at the bottom you've got
Japan the lowest tier eight of the set
right oh you may be interested to know
that in the 69 economies that they look
at sub-saharan Africa has the highest
tier eight up around 69 or 70 percent
anybody care to guess why hung a chef
subsistence businesses to just having to
create their own job because the
infrastructure of large companies and
they did that's it you got to create
your own job you have no choice so the
tea right tire
country that has a lower degree of
economic development anyway this is
what's been going on for the last 10
years or so in the US and select Asia
economies this whole point that I was
starting to we were starting to talk
about the T rate tends to be higher when
GDP per person income per person is
lower you see this range between 0 and
maybe ten or fifteen thousand dollars is
you see a lot of countries who are have
relatively high tier eights here then
you see between about 18,000 and about
forty thousand dollars this kind of
middle range these are the efficiency
economies that they were talking about
in in GE em and then as you go further
you see a really entrepreneurship of
opportunity this is where there aren't
any salary jobs so you got to make your
own and this is where you become an
entrepreneur because you believe that
it's the best outcome the best thing you
can do for your career you get the best
return if you look at the u.s. attitudes
they go on in this survey and here's the
tier eight thirteen percent of the
people who are not actively engaged in
entrepreneurship forty-three percent of
the respondents saw good opportunities
for entrepreneurs of the people not
engaged in entrepreneurial activities 53
4 i'm sorry fifty-six percent of them
thought that they had the capabilities
to be an entrepreneur we're very
self-confident in the US then of the
people who are not engaged in
entrepreneur thirty two percent of them
said that fear of failure was a major
factor in not starting a business and
one other thing that they ask everybody
is do you see yourself starting a
business in the foreseeable future so of
course these are people who are not
already doing entrepreneurship same
number thirteen percent if
proneural intentions is greater or the
same amount as this then you kind of see
an uptick on the whole kind of attitude
toward entrepreneurship there people are
just waiting for a better opportunity so
if you see how the u.s. compares to some
of the other places in China and
Thailand Thailand had the highest tier 8
right and china now has a tier 8 that's
the same as the u.s. not a whole lot of
difference in the perceived
opportunities between the u.s. and
Thailand fewer opportunities were
perceived in China last year when I did
this more people saw opportunities in
China the perceived capabilities the
u.s. is extremely self confident I'm not
really sure this this figure I'm
suspicious of any kind of a
self-reporting survey like this because
people tend to be humble in Asia and so
I'm not really sure if they're just
under playing it or whatever but
certainly the percentage of people
seeing opportunities needs to be about
the same or even a little bit greater
than the number of people who see
themselves is able to take take
advantage of it fear of failure was a
major demotivator in thailand fifty
percent of the people were worried about
you know what would happen if they
failed the US and China are pretty much
similar in regard to fear of failure on
the entrepreneurial intentions notice
that both Thailand and China had higher
intention than their actual tr8 so
probably there are people waiting for
the economy to pick up a little bit and
for the opportunity to get a little
better it's not that they feel like
there's something systemic that's going
to prevent them from being an
entrepreneur now if you look at
singapore taiwan in South Korea the T
rates are lower except in Singapore than
in
the u.s. the perceived opportunities is
wide range but nothing as much as you
see on the US respondents especially
South Korea is very negative about the
opportunities for entrepreneurs you've
got an economy where large businesses
control a major you know major segments
of the population it's really hard to
get to market without having some sort
of a connection to one of the big
business groups everybody is very much
kind of right in the middle of a quarter
of the population seeing themselves as
having the ability to be entrepreneurs
this is kind of a negative factor far-
compared to the u.s. the fear of failure
is pretty high all other than it is for
the US and the intention to start a
business at some point is relatively
high for all of these so again you see
people who are biding their time and
waiting for the right opportunity then
you get to Malaysia and Japan with yeah
this is just really sad about Japan six
percent of the people not engaged in
entrepreneurship thought that there were
activities to be an entrepreneur that
there are opportunities to be successful
as an entrepreneur nine percent of them
thought they had the abilities to be an
entrepreneur fifty-three percent of them
were worried about fail and two percent
of the people not engaged and actively
engaged in entrepreneurship we're
willing to think about starting the
company in the foreseeable future I have
to say that this tracks the talks that I
give in Japan where I'll go to a talk
you know a room of a hundred students or
200 students eyes how many people would
like to start a company i'll get one or
two hands raised so that's kind of a
deep blue funk there red colored on the
on the chart but
very definitely a negative attitude
toward this so let's look at the
environment a little bit more and then
we'll go on and have some Q&A questions
about this last thing the attitudes go
ahead fools how did they yeah you know
it's a much going on in the business
schools trying to change that attitude
among people and yes entrepreneur
education is a very popular thing just
fell over not down do anything with it
in any economic equation you got supply
side and demand side and the schools are
really supply side and unless something
can be done to make it better access to
the market and really being successful
plus a lot of Asian entrepreneurs will
start a company without having a sense
of the growth expectations that we have
when we start companies here they don't
expect to make the next Google and you
can go too far that way I mean sometimes
I think the mood around Stanford is a
little too much that everybody has to
start in the next Google but if you have
a niche family business as the ultimate
outcome of an entrepreneurial activity
that's not enough of an upside to really
get good people involved in the in the
program the founder will be there but
who do you get to come work for the
company so I'm concerned that the
business schools are half of the
equation the other half has yet to be
solved you had a question ok so anyway
let's look at this environment a little
bit more um yes entrepreneurial behavior
is affected first of all by the presence
or absence of career alternatives water
your choices go ahead get into that what
how would you compare the VC structure
compared to what you see here in silver
capital yeah exactly got a couple of
slides coming all right okay and yeah
we'll talk more about that other
questions
okay so yeah the economic structure and
dynamics the availability of capital and
the conditions for accessing it the
labor market issues especially the
fluidity of the labor market and it's
not only the people who will be
entrepreneurs who are important probably
the single most important group of
people in Silicon Valley that nobody
talks about are the people who go to
work for growth phase companies
companies that have 50 employees and
they're on the way to having 5,000
they're not founders they're not really
entrepreneurs but they're willing to
risk their careers on a high growth
company for a few stock options and you
know the chance to buy a house in Palo
Alto sometime so the availability of
human resources is a major issue behind
the label markets you do have
infrastructure issues and then you've
got these kind of cultural expectations
one of my favorites that I've mentioned
in quite a few of my speeches is a
professor at a Japanese University asked
his students if they were interested in
becoming entrepreneurs nobody said yes
he sent out the question here like 300
students and he did an analysis of the
answers that came back and the single
most common answer was my mom would be
against the idea so it's interesting I
heard the same thing from somebody from
India though that in India you can't get
married if you become an entrepreneur
first so yeah go ahead a time you
actually last year but so venture
capitalists in the US going back to the
further build up the first bubble had to
actually spend time on the phone with
the mothers of brides that we're
considering a young Indian men were
working in high-tech companies here
convince them that those companies
revival or gotta get the whole family to
buy them Kate absolutely yeah so anyway
let's let's take a look at this a little
bit more if you look at how an
innovation system works
it really is composed of people and
capital and ideas one definition of
innovation is that an innovation is a
new combination of people an idea and
capital and of course it rests on
infrastructure the entrepreneurial
culture is really a dynamic behind the
system the framework you need really all
these kinds of people to have a
successful entrepreneurial sector in the
economy the knowledge workers are
probably the single most important group
that is not mentioned a whole lot o
capital for a real innovation based
system you need a real good R&D funding
coming in from somewhere even at the
stages before commercialization basic
science and technology the role of the
government in an innovation system
cannot be underestimated then you run
into the high-risk investment capital
that is what most people talk about in
an entrepreneurial system there's one
other very important source of capital
for startup companies and that's revenue
how can you get customers and can you
really get enough revenue to gradually
move your growth away from the investors
and into you know a revenue positive
model the ideas are going to come from
multiple disciplines not any single
discipline and then look at the kind of
creativity too many places that look at
entrepreneurship are looking at good R&D
people and good technical creativity but
figuring out how to make money with
something is as important or as
difficult a challenge for creativity as
it is to come up with the invention
anyway and then as an entrepreneur you
have to be very clever how to obtain
resources how do you do your marketing
without spending any money you know of
course you have done no money for
advertising of course you can't pay
people what do you do so you know this
kind of this really the elements are not
to be it's not a simple
kind of thing but it's really the
dynamics that kind of push people
together and have them really everybody
being interested in what's next what's
the next new thing and how can i play is
really the focus of a lot of the human
networking in Silicon Valley it's not
just that people come together and talk
to each other it's what they talk about
so not everybody is going to start their
company but you do need to have good
social standing and it also really helps
here that you know I bet if I asked for
people to raise their hands how many
people know someone who's starting a
company or has started a company just
about everybody would raise your hands
here not in a lot of places but along
with that kind of experience come sort
of the sense of whether this idea is
going to work or whether this is a dog
and also the willingness to really think
big and be ready to change the world is
part of this whole entrepreneurial
attitude for it really to turn into a
system like the valley you have to have
this iteration you have to see this
happening over and over again so that
the path to entrepreneurship the path to
working in a startup company becomes
relatively straightforward becomes
transparent to people so that they see
how to do it as part of that exits are
critical right now exits in Asia are not
nearly as big as they are here most
exits in the u.s. come from acquisitions
by big companies most exits in Asia come
from I POS unless the company dies and
the IPOs tend to be small they tend to
create a lot of niche companies where
the biggest problem is the founder of
the company finding somebody to take
over when he or she is ready to retire
so anyway these are kind of you know you
need this kind of system going on let's
look at capital there are a lot of
different kinds of capital that are
involved in the growth of a company not
just the startup phase it's really hard
to get data about the first stages of
this process angel investors don't have
to make public their investments there
are groups of angels that do make public
and do show you their portfolios but
it's the VC community where you've got a
number of different kind of surveys of
what's going on in venture capital us
baseline is that we've had a reduction
between the number of deals and also the
amount invested between 2011 and 2012
it's not a huge decline but it's a
noticeable decline and of this the
biggest kind of decline happened at the
seed stage harder to get early stage
money in venture capital now I bet if
you ask an entrepreneur they would say
yeah tell me something else I don't know
the sectors that people are investing in
here and all these slides will be posted
the the sectors that people are
investing in software is huge we have
the information technology third
revolution which is cloud computing that
is pushing a lot of mobile applications
pushing a lot of you know new kinds of
businesses that were not possible for
location-based services would not be
possible without cloud computing so sure
enough software is still in the top
there were more deals and more money
within the software in 2012 even though
the total amount of VC in 2012 was less
so if you look at where the biggest
decline is industry and energy nobody
likes of
solar cell companies anymore right this
is a noticeable drop that probably has
to do with a few high-profile failures
medical devices are down quite a bit
that's an interesting decline I'm
surprised to see that I'm also surprised
to see IT services down as much as it is
what you're seeing is a gradual increase
in deal size too in a lot of these
sectors the average size of a venture
capital deal is probably a little bit
bigger in 2012 than it was in 2011 so
that's the u.s. baseline head-to-head
let's look at China China remember went
from a 24-percent tier 8 to a 13-percent
tier 8 between 2011 and 2012 well the
amount of venture capital invested in
2011 was six billion dollars us the
amount investment in 2012 was 3.7
billion that's a forty percent decline
the number of deals declined by forty
four percent so this is a huge change in
the customer services sector actually
was relatively stable I didn't put the
2011 data in but it didn't drop that
much information technologies and the
other sectors were dropping quite a bit
more from 2011 on one thing to note
about venture capital deals in China the
average deal size in China is over 11
million dollars that's considerably
higher bigger than the average deal size
in the US and what it means is that
you've got a lot of big projects that
are being invested probably more like
private equity investments here in the
US not as much investing in a technology
to incubate as you are investing in a
factory to get things out to people so
that's what's going on in China in India
even though the total economy declined
quite a bit in India you see a decline a
little bit of a decline in venture
capital but not a whole lot what you're
seeing is a lot of noise and the
quarters in 2007 2008 was the huge peak
in India venture capital investment and
then 2009 sure enough after the 2008
downturn it tanked their investors
stopped letting their money go there as
well um so that's the way that looks in
by industry information technology and
information technology services are by
far the biggest sector for investment in
India healthcare and life sciences is
good agribusiness is noticeable that is
not noticeable in either China or the
u.s. you do have some interesting
investments in manufacturing now one
fascinating point is that Brazil has
really hit the radar of investors for
technology companies and that may be
taking a lot of money away from the
other BRICS so this is kind of what the
landscape looks like for VC by industry
in India now it's always hard for a
startup company to get its first
customer in the US open innovation where
the big companies are always on the
lookout for things that they can scoop
up from the little companies the
startups is a major driving factor
behind first customer acquisition and
also exit in the u.s. system so you know
my sense is that people have focused a
lot on the supply side they focused a
lot on the entrepreneur production
startup company creation and haven't
focused nearly as much on startup
company growth in Asia
and thats pretty much applies all the
way across the Asian economies to a
certain extent we see a much more mature
system here in the Silicon Valley if you
look at the labor market I found an
absolutely fascinating report by the
Department of Labor in the middle of
last year it was a 30-year longitudinal
study and they found that between the
ages of 18 to 46 people in the US had an
average of 11.3 jobs Wow if you have
university a university degree you have
an even higher job turnover rate so this
is where you get the sense that you know
you stay in a job for three years or so
and if you can't find a better job
there's something wrong with you it's an
incredibly mobile labor market even
among 42 46 year olds thirty-three
percent of their jobs ended in less than
a year and sixty-nine percent ended in
less than five years what happens in a
situation of this kind of uncertainty
you better learn how to be an
entrepreneur even if you're going to go
to work for somebody else's company you
have to be in charge of your own career
no one is going to set the rails for you
and so this is a you know definitely
promoting entrepreneurship in the US as
well as all sorts of feelings of
uncertainty in Asia the labor markets
are quite fluid in China and India
although what you get is you get
competition among prestige companies
it's very hard to get and keep people in
a company because they'll be scouted out
scooped up by somebody else but the
people doing the scooping tend to be
bigger companies the labor markets are
not fluid at all in Japan and Korea
there's this tradition of kind of
lifetime employment that is not really
codified in any kind of a contract but
has definitely it goes back to this old
efficiency based efficiency driven
economy where there was a shortage of
Labor and so you had to give great
conditions to the people to get them to
come work in your company I think that
this is changing the economic slowdown
in China is going to make it harder for
a lot of university students to get a
job it's also going to reduce the number
of jobs that people can get on the
outside anyway the aging population
however works against that as the
population continues to age it may be
there may be less pressure in Japan last
year the total number of jobs in the
labor force declined and yet
unemployment declined even more because
the population is starting to shrink so
this is going to kind of have an
opposite impact may actually make make
it less attractive to do the risky path
of being an entrepreneur there is
increased international mobility we're
trying to do better about bringing in
gifted young people into the US and in
general international mobility is up and
a lot of the new industries that we have
start-ups in now are intrinsically
global one of the themes that we're
going to look at this quarter is the
this emerging wave of global startups
that where startups are really and the
entrepreneurs are trying to go global
earlier rather than later in their
development infrastructure yeah every
year dun and Bradstreet does a ranking
of where it's easiest to do business and
Singapore usually comes out number one
and Hong Kong is real close to it in
terms of the quality of labor contracts
and also the ability of the legal system
to enforce contracts and that kind of
thing Oh China is low on this it's hard
to do business in China
you have a lot of complexity you have a
lot of opaque relationships with
government you have a lot of things
where guanxi who you know and how you
know them becomes as important as what
you have in your company but one
noticeable trend is I'm seeing more y
combinator type incubators and I just
use them or 500 startups kind of as an
example because these are incubators
that are focusing more on very
short-term programs three to six months
programs not on giving a company cheap
rent until they have a better you know
financial situation that's not the point
of these new incubators they really are
educational programs so there are three
examples that I'm personally aware of um
this is kind of the summary for the talk
and then we've got a few minutes for Q&A
there have been a lot of systemic
challenges in Asia that have worked to
inhibit entrepreneurial activity the
lack of fluidity in the labor market but
that's fading away the whole idea of
bigger companies having higher prestige
that being the place where your mom
wants you to go to work you know there's
a reason why that this happened but
there's a lot of dissatisfaction there's
a lot of lack of trust against big
companies by young people I think a real
generational changes in progress
especially in East Asia you have several
things that go back to Confucian ideals
really the whole idea of education in
Asia is a Confucian apprenticeship
system the professor is the master and
sits on the throne and the students try
to figure out what the professor is
talking about I wish I could get a job
like that anyway it doesn't promote
radical creativity but again I'm seeing
new kinds of approaches I'm seeing new
faculty who are very much Western in
there
which to having Socratic dialogues with
their students who are they're learning
from their students as well as teaching
them the leadership comes with age is a
big thing how can you be taken seriously
as an entrepreneur if you're 23 years
old in a system where you've got to have
gray hair before people take you
seriously how can you have mentoring in
a system where the person with gray hair
if they tell you something can you
really tell them I don't think so not
this time you know I think that the
mentoring works here in the valley
partly because the young people take all
the advice they think it over and then
they make the decision of what has to be
done financing still favors low risk
over high reward in Asia at the stages
of the rapid growth like in China and
India people want a sure thing they want
relatively rapid revenue they don't want
to delay this by a few years they really
want to move right now you are seeing a
growth of venture capital I think the
break in the pipeline is of the angel
stage and just about everywhere because
angel investors here tend to act very
professionally and exercise due
diligence and they come together in
groups they really study what the
investment is all about and a little too
much fly by the night and sometimes the
lack of exits is a big issue in Asia and
I do think that you see Emma day on the
rise and so the rise of open innovation
will be a big wave that's just now
beginning to appear in the various Asia
economies so that's my prepared remarks
we've got a few minutes for discussion I
want to tell you that next week I've got
exactly the right person to come in and
talk about this mystery of Southeast
Asia why they're still growing so well
dr. red ruby she is coming back from
Thomas at University and Thailand
and we'll talk about the role of Asia in
the glutton Southeast Asia in the global
supply chain two weeks from today I'm
really excited because the head of the
Stanford alumni association's industry
chapter is an angel investor in India
and she's bringing one of the top-ranked
you know one of the top 10 innovative
companies from India with her the CEO of
in Oz is coming in along with paula mera
wallah and we'll also if skype works
have the CEO of red bus which is a
really interesting online bus ticket
service in India participating in the
panel discussion live then after that
we've got a presentation from Korea will
have some presentations from China and
Japan I think it will be a great quarter
but I'd like to open up the floor to
questions now or comments what do you
think yeah we're relating to your last
point about the exit surprisingly little
that there's such difficulty with exits
given the nature large companies in
Japan and Korea you would think the
samsungs would be looking for new and
innovative companies and scoop them up
like Cisco deserts on one of the
problems with a big company and this is
the famous model of open innovation by
Professor cheese borough over at
Berkeley is that the big companies in
the old days like Xerox and AT&T and IBM
did everything in-house they had company
internal R&D that nobody could match
this leads them to become a little too
happy with themselves and so everything
comes from company internal R&D they
don't buy ideas from the outside this
started to change in the US about 15
years ago and one really important point
that not many people talk about is that
a company must have someone
strategically considering technology
alternatives outside of their own R&D
group in order to effectively work with
open innovation you buy something from
the outside precisely because you're not
doing
inside the company and the pride that
goes along with prestige and being a big
company makes out a real barrier and a
lot of places plus if you have this
situation where nobody really wants to
take responsibility which is a kind of
universal characteristic of big
companies there are a million ways to
exercise passive resistance against
integrating something from outside even
if you do acquire it so this is a hard
one that the valley is remarkably
successful in adopting Cisco was
probably the first poster child for this
but now Google is Google is doing a
great open innovation based thing where
internally at spending six billion
dollars on R&D but it's buying dozens of
companies every year now so an
interesting point about state university
education for entrepreneurship being
supply side so I'm going to turn it back
on you and ask you what could be done in
Japan and Korea and other markets where
there's so much fear of risk there's so
much doubt about starting a company or
lack of desire to so what could be done
in those markets to change things what
would be most effective in your eyes I
think two things first of all there is
money in Japan if we're talking about
Japan especially I think some investor
education programs would be great you
know how to achieve a twenty-five
percent annual return right the other
thing that I think would be good would
be some sort of a subsidy program for
buying things from startup companies
that could even be something local
governments could do okay if you're
going to buy your phone system buy it
from a local startup right where you
assist companies in getting their first
customers but I do think that just in
general the education program has to
focus more on growth and not just on
creation
relatively strong linkages between
Australia and the the other Asian
countries education capital etc where
where do they fit in this the value
chain of high-tech on a macro economic
side i'm afraid that Australia is still
primarily kind of doing what Brazil is
doing on the other side of the southern
hemisphere supplying natural resources
and there are good you know there's
great things happening down in Australia
and it could be that what they need is a
little bit more world press about the
opportunities there and so forth but
they don't really have you know I think
ultimately what you're going to get is
not so much a national based system
where Korea does this or Japan does this
you're really going to have an
innovation center based system that may
look like the ancient world of
city-states you've got the Shanghai
system you've got the Sol system you've
got the Kyoto system you've got you know
wherever that these innovation centers
are going to be real centers of growth
supporting the markets around them but
the real interesting places to live are
going to be the city states that's light
18 you talked about the three different
stages of economic development you
mentioned that the Chinese goal right
now is to go from stage one stage three
can you talk about the likelihood of
them being successful in doing this and
this is just a personal input when I
have friends that return from China one
of their universal comments is a lack of
interest in basic rd in really
fundamental understandings of how things
work so how can you go from stage 1 2 3
if you don't really invest in the rd
well first of all the government is
investing in basic science and
technology on a 50-year plan for did a
five-year plan their investments are in
basic science as well as in applied and
I really have to give the government of
China great credit for that they're
really trying to build the country up
boot strap it up to have a science and
tech no
ecology base equal to you know as much
as advanced as anybody up until now the
flow of money has been very rational why
take risk if you don't have to in order
to get a good return and I think that
has stopped a lot of closer in rd in
China from commercializing like it does
here where you really have to come up
with a kind of striking new technology
to get on anybody's roadmap here in
China there's been so much opportunity
just to build out the current
infrastructure oh that you really don't
need to take technology risk you don't
have to have over the long run they're
in a very good position in the short run
there in a very difficult transitional
time it remains to be seen what China is
really going to feel like on the ground
at seven percent growth than it was at
ten percent growth and historical
precedent is hard to really calculate on
this we really don't have any precedents
like China we're in a generation since
1990 you realize that the economy of
China is 31 times as big as it was in
1990 and you know that just doesn't
happen for something that scale so there
are all kinds of things that can happen
in China a government that has as much
power as they do in China governments
could sure screw up business I mean III
have to say that's a systemic danger on
the other hand the government there is
run by technocrats and so they tend to
do a better job of things than a lot of
governments do it's a good question i
would say that over the long run china
looks great over the medium term it's a
difficult place to do business
and we'll bring some people in who are
actually helping angel angel stage
investors and also venture capitalists
who are helping foreign companies
foreign you know nan Chinese
entrepreneurs to be successful there and
that's where I think we can most that's
the lesson I think we need the most out
of this ok good question other questions
you have any thoughts on the challenges
in China regarding the migrant workforce
dynamics some countries of city exactly
so individuals wanting more of a choice
in staying with the position staying
with the company or staying in a
provenance well increase if China would
satisfied with moving from stage one to
Sage to this would have been a natural
thing it would have been difficult to
manage but these people would have
gotten relatively low paying factory
jobs that would have kept them employed
in the cities as it is you have such a
rapidly changing situation that there's
a lot less stability and a lot more
possibility for social problems so is
certainly bears watching I don't have a
better crystal ball than that maybe one
more question or comment we've got some
refreshments outside and I hope that we
can stand around and get to know each
other go ahead do you think is a global
scale scale so Korea Taiwan Hong Kong
all have a certain size of the market of
course yeah you only wait for them to
grow further that is outside of their
country so that is also a big drawback
but open yeah the other thing is can I
can I stop you there because that's a
great point good feeder is disadvantaged
or it's a very interesting advantage
think about Silicon Valley we have a
totally uninteresting market size in
Silicon Valley if it weren't for the
American market and now for the Pacific
Rim market we wouldn't be able to agree
create
these world leading companies we depend
on them gaining their strength from the
world market so I do think that it's not
automatically a bad thing okay therefore
companies are successful missing China
and Japan alone different entries have a
very hard time to internationalize to
grow to nationally and that's what is
preventing them from going for take you
for example by who try to go in Japan
and Taiwan but never succeeded anybody
is saying many of those companies try to
grow outside of the home market yeah but
never successful didn't do too well that
it's hard to do global business and I
think that um what I see that worries me
in China is an increasingly domestic
focus I mean it used to be that the big
Chinese companies were really providing
product to the EU u.s. and Japan they
were kind of had intrinsically global
business models as a country becomes
more focused in on itself the danger of
losing the benefits for all of us of a
global business environment increase and
I think that that's one thing that I see
is kind of a cloud on the horizon and it
could also happen in other places you
know Japan is obsessed with going back
to two percent inflation so Japan is
looking at its own fiscal policy in its
own you know whatever oh that may not be
the best thing for Japan I'm not making
any comment about the current government
but just if you make your if you look at
yourself as an isolated part of the
system you make decisions that are
different from seeing yourself as part
of an integrated whole and I do think
that we've done a great job in Silicon
Valley as seeing ourselves as part of an
integrated whole that's one of the
things that the companies here have done
well with even though I know several
cases of companies that were too slow to
go
of overseas markets or they didn't do it
in a good way it is harder it's a lot
harder to do successful business on a
world scale this is another reason I
want to do this theme of global startups
this quarter is I really think this is
an interesting new term that I'm hearing
from a lot of people in a lot of
different places and we're in a good
position to take advantage of it yaps
these days Yeah right and it is an
absolute what's falling into the day and
have some refreshments outside thanks
everybody
you